hi welcome to Julian and Jenna's [ __ ]
podcast okay so before we [ __ ] start
talking about anything let me tell you
why we're doing this
I don't watch podcasts I don't listen to
podcasts I don't I don't know I don't
like it's just not my world but we did
used to use stream a lot I personally
used to use stream for like years every
Friday night and then Julian I used to
use dream together and we would just
have sort of this core group which we're
on Ustream right now so they can see us
and they're going to help contribute to
some of the conversation but um we had
like a core group of people when just
sit there when we were like getting
drunk like now like just having some
drinks kicking it and we would just sit
there and have the most epic
conversations as when I get drunk when I
get drunk that's all I want to do is
just get real Chatty Cathy and talk to
anybody and [ __ ] like you know what
he knew about these Congress yeah it
happened and then no one would know
about no no so we asked on Ustream a
long time ago if we made a podcast if
that would be fun or not so we [ __ ]
we got some mics like yeah this isn't
the most professional setup ever but
we're just gonna [ __ ] do alive you
know what I mean and like zero
expectations like I don't I don't know
what this is like like some of them
might be [ __ ] 10 minutes some of them
might be 3 hours yeah our goal is to not
have any goals or rules or anything we
just kind of want to get on the mic and
make it more lasting you know we have
these conversations and then they go
away and we wake up and they never be
existing yeah so we won't want them to
exist yeah we want it and we want to
come up with topics and you know discuss
them whatever but like I said there's no
rules we want to talk about what we
talked about and and whatever happens
happens but we're really excited to just
like finally [ __ ] do it like actually
get it done yeah um yeah that's it
that's all I got that's it so here come
dat podcast Oh what like I don't even
look I'm not gonna [ __ ] sit here and
think about topics I just want to
[ __ ] go no no we did have some
earlier yeah we want to have an idea
that you talked about on Ustream yeah
you wanna start
okay okay so just you know we're on
Ustream right now like a 15 group 15
person group [ __ ] medias terrible I
know it's so sick I took a picture um
but ok so here's here's one thing I
thought would be a good topic um
goodnight here's taking here's cuz we're
on the computer audio so we're still
talking and yeah so we're on like 15
mediums and so many things happening um
we were talking about how kids today are
in a completely different world than we
were as kids or anyone was as kids
because the technology that they're
growing up with is unlike anything that
anyone has ever grown up in we all have
it now at our current age but growing up
as a kid going through school having
these iPhones and iPads and access to
the entire Internet is something that's
like just this is the first time it's
ever happened so I kind of wanted to
start the discussion you know a lot of
people talk about how these kids are
antisocial and they're not really
learning like people but could the
argument be made these kids are getting
more stimulation and they're becoming
more advanced by growing up in this
environment mmm what an interesting
thought no I'm kidding um I think
honestly the only argument that I can
concretely make in terms of perhaps
getting smarter is that when you're
visually stimulated it goes to the back
of your brain and thinks it's called
your [ __ ] awesome little lobe that's
the part of your brain that controls
vision and like what you see and it
stimulates that part of your brain I
feel like because when you're a kid the
most visually well when we grew up the
most visually stimulating thing that
you're going to see is like your [ __ ]
swing set and your slide and your
[ __ ] friends with their real faces
and a book maybe like some TV on
occasion I was born in 1986 you're born
in the 90s but like you know we had to
go outside soon as we come home we
[ __ ] get outside but kids now the
video games you have TV you have an
endless supply of things that are
visually stimulating your brain so I
feel like it would be interesting in 20
or 30 years to do some sort of scan on
brains like I think that that part of
your brain
be much more efficient much more like
maybe [ __ ] I don't want to say bigger
but like that's the that's what
separates us from [ __ ] apes right we
have more than just a primitive brain we
have logic and reasoning and all of
these things I think that their brains
will develop differently for sure and
that they're nasty at [ __ ] seeing
things with their eyes honestly [ __ ]
hand-eye coordination oh sorry yeah
they're talking about that just the idea
of it when I was talking about on
Ustream that's the thing like we don't
know anything and the only thing in 30
years we're going to be able to okay do
scans do some research because it's
happening right now so we really don't
know what what the effect is or anything
like that but what's like what about how
you know in a normal household today and
that the century and the age and the
technology age we live in a kid can
learn about [ __ ] that's happening in the
world so much faster than the parent
yeah the parents completely disconnected
if you look at the kid who's on Twitter
who's on Instagram who's on everything
all day all the time yeah they're more
connected yeah ah [ __ ] I remember you
had to wait until the [ __ ] news came
on or you got a [ __ ] newspaper like
that is not news efficient whatsoever
you need to know what's happening when
it's happening well that's also
something like like I don't know if you
consider what I do like just being on
the internet like relevancy is sort of
everything and if you're like days
behind then it doesn't [ __ ] nobody
gives a [ __ ] you want to do Harlem shake
yeah you would do harm log yeah let me
put out a Harlem shake video
hi I'm 40 years old and I just found all
these videos like it's its own there's
no longer relevant
relevancy sort of everything and kids
are very much aware of that whereas the
generation of our parents are still sort
of on that train where it's like I think
I get it but I don't know whether like I
don't know Jade yeah but they don't
[ __ ] they don't care either yeah
there's more I feel like it's part of it
that they're so hell-bent on staying
with what they know right you you take
for example someone like my mom for
those of you on [ __ ] Ustream podcast
video whatever my mom is on Twitter 24
[ __ ]
seven mind you this is the person that I
had to change my real name from jenna
mourey not my real name in real life on
YouTube I had to change my name from
jenna mourey jennamarbles because she
was trying to get a job at the time and
she was like your last names ruining all
of my google searches so can you please
like use a different name or like an
alias and now she is just all [ __ ] in
she put all of her chips on that
internet dick she's all in she tweets it
the most ridiculous hours of the day
you
all right so yeah I guess it only has
eight minutes me we cut out figured our
stride yeah but yeah she my mom that's
an example of someone that could easily
blame their age their generation on not
being able to understand but instead has
sort of embraced it to their advantage
her advantage being laughing yeah at the
Internet yeah it's not like I don't
think my mom was really using it for any
purpose no I mean but and then it's like
her peers are probably just kind of like
what is all this but she's like more
connected than anyone her age yeah you
know she's your mama have twitter yeah
your mama's Instagram my mom's Twitter
but the tag is called poppity pup-pup so
she made the Twitter for her dog and
she's tweeted it for it probably like
once for every year that she's at hahaha
well it definitely presents an obstacle
when you're trying to be an adult and
someone's like oh what's your Twitter
and you're like oh it's a puppet II pup
pup like two peas in the middle three of
them yeah yeah okay
like why kids someone on Ustream said
kids can't spell anymore because of
texting that's actually a really great
point and I when I did the Sirius XM
[ __ ] the YouTube 15 on hits one not
not a plug just telling you what I did
today um although plug because I love
that [ __ ] show um we uh introduced
not introduced cuz on YouTube but like
for the first time on the show it was
the weird al' yankovic [ __ ] what's
the name of that song ah something words
fancy word Christ no word crimes it was
a blurred lines parody called word
crimes and Weird Al it's just the master
of musical parodies but he was sort of
harping on the fact that kids have grown
up with so much technology that they
have become so reliant dependent on it
so they don't spell correctly but my
okay that's we don't need to go there
like we understand that argument is
valid but my argument is that we'll just
to play devil's advocate that you know
it's a whole different language the
Internet
and to get it and to use it effectively
is you know strikes chords of people
humor wise with especially humor I guess
humor is my main point like if you can
take you like I could sit down and write
a perfectly grammatically perfect you
know what blog entry [ __ ] thesis
whatever the [ __ ] you want me to write
but to use it to your advantage for
comedic purposes I think takes skill and
why not embrace it because that shit's
[ __ ] hilarious the amount of hoops
that I have had to jump through to try
to explain even in the simplest vein
what spoderman is my mom is like
baffling I know I can't explain it and
either get it or you don't you either
were you know you were involved in the
process that made that funny or you're
not boilerman is a Twitter by the way if
those of you that doorman please Twitter
accounts butter literally phonetically
speaking spelled spoderman pls spoderman
please yeah
we're talking about our parents being
internet savvy or not your dad's pretty
internet savvy your dad liked my do for
those of you that don't know Julian's
dad is I don't know why you would but
Julian's dad works at maker but he's
leaving maker he left he left already
yeah so Julian's dad was a stand-up
comedian for years and years and then
started a company on his own and then
[ __ ] was part of a partner and then
[ __ ] worked for maker and I left
maker like that's pretty [ __ ] the
internet savvy you're her maker no he's
definitely an exception to the rule yeah
well they're people yep
does your dad tweet and [ __ ] do all
social media is not his thing he doesn't
even follow me which I don't even think
he knows he might have on for I don't
even he's just uh social media that's
what's weird because you can understand
part of the internet but not the whole
thing because yeah you know he's
produced all kinds of YouTube stuff and
he's worked on the Internet per se for
years and years but he still tweets like
a 12 year old every single tweet is like
political and you don't want to read it
yeah like I don't think my dad has
Twitter but my dad has certainly grasped
on to the fact that Facebook is the
thing yeah so I'm pretty sure my dad is
a Facebook yeah I think we're friends I
don't know but I also this is why my dad
has no validity though my dad is a
Google Plus Oh God my dad uses Google
Plus I think what yes yeah not dear
Google Plus stop making Google+ happen
it's never gonna happen
stop making shop so fetch bikinis [ __ ]
me miss I said cookie with the P I'll
give you the P for those of you that
know what [ __ ] Summer Heights High is
and you'll get that otherwise we just
looked crazy but it's okay
otherwise you should watch that it's a
great [ __ ] show you miss Chris Lilly
is a [ __ ] genius that's what he's a
genius missus no but back to what we
were talking about about kids being
smarter now yeah but what about okay so
maybe your visual center of your brain
might be significantly stronger which
has certainly been the trend over the
last I would say
50 years like kids are becoming more and
more I don't know good at visual
learning like when you talk like just
talk about like types of learning you
have audio learners visual learners that
sort of thing like you a tactile learner
like kids are becoming more and more
skewed towards visual learners I think
because when you're a child that's how
you learn how to learn right like this
generation is learning how to learn
through their eyes instead of any other
way yeah this is just the most efficient
at this point yeah cuz everything's
available on your iPad and you have to
[ __ ] look at your iPad yeah that's
true not it's [ __ ] true it's like
that method of learning that you learn
the most basic human functions they
continue that method of learning
everything right what kind of learner
are you ah I don't know how to answer
that question say you were to study for
a test
yeah or something I'd have to write it
down every time I wrote my answers I
wrote my notes yeah action gotten to my
brain see that's exactly I am and also
if I were to ever read a book or write a
paper I'm not one of those people that
can sit there with [ __ ]
headphones listening to music I can't do
that I can't [ __ ] have TV I need to
be like in a silent little cubicle
whereas I feel like maybe this is just a
hypothesis that the generation that's
younger than us because they're so used
to multitasking and Multimedia's at all
times like they're being bombarded
across their brains eyes ears everything
constantly and everything seems to move
too slow
and let's just this this this this this
yeah perhaps they would be able to write
a paper with like a hurricane going on
seriously and like some smooth rap jams
and like [ __ ] yeah get it just from
talking to kids like I have a younger
stepbrother Jacob you know Jacob him
yeah uh having a conversation with him
is just impossible
how old is Jacob he's he's fifteen yeah
he's fifteen is going to be a sophomore
in high school but having a conversation
with him is one of the most challenging
things because he first of all he talked
so fast
and he talks at a speed where his brain
moves but no one else's so he talks
really fast but at the same time he'll
move from topic to topic to topic and
you'll be like wait a minute
I was saying this and he's like oh yeah
no I know I answered that like yeah they
moved on and it's just like it's not
even something you can learn it's just
how you brain grows there's we have been
on there's so many synapses happening
they all connect to each other in his
brain but not necessarily in your brain
although I well just to say this much
he's your family member so it's
difficult to connect with him because
your trial
stepbrother he's you're trying to
connect with him in a bonding male
bonding brother level but for me I feel
like when I talk to Jacob I since I'm an
outsider I'm not in the family I can
connect with Jacob because I appreciate
the a DD because sometimes that's how my
brain works and ya know it's how
teenagers know yeah absolutely
I feel it yeah in like 30 seconds I
think it's gonna stop but I'm not sure
because it might not stupid alright just
in case we have like 10 seconds here's a
break brought to you by our sponsors
[ __ ] nobody because ain't nobody got
mo [ __ ] time for that dick Mac
sponsors whatever is in the didn't stop
it's still going well my staff in like 5
sec oh 3 mm I don't know what about the
cameras the game we're gonna yeah I'm
the camera always changed settings that
might never stop ever ever uh alright
well I mean if it gets past 20 minutes
and a half we'll just keep going because
that's interesting for someone on
Ustream said for me it depends on the
subject which i think is valid like if
you're maybe for doing something that
really challenges you mentally you can't
have a lot of distractions for me
personally like I was nasty at science
so like yeah bring on all the
distractions or something that's
enjoyable but maybe for somebody who's
really challenging you can't have all
these things that are faring in your
brain yeah what's like your worst
subject chillin
I think one of my like three C's in
college came from stats that statistics
are the devil that's it like awful we
have to take a lot of stats for
psychology not cool it's just hard my
whole thing with stats is you okay you
show Matt so you must saying that yeah
yeah you struggle so hard on one thing
right it's like a formula or a concept
and you're struggling forever on it
right and then one day you're like oh my
god I get it
and you're [ __ ] the man and you're
writing all these formulas like yes and
the test comes you get an A and then you
move on and the next chapter it's like
okay this is kind of like it but it's
nothing like it and you think it's
exactly the same but it just fools you
yeah and then you have to learn on top
of that and a weird what I just could
never do that I was yeah yeah I'm I
totally understand that because it if
you fall behind even a little bit in
math you just sort of [ __ ] and it's
sort of the same thing with science
and we'll languages too but in my
opinion the one thing that my brain just
cannot do is [ __ ] history like I in
high school one quarter
I got a D in history like that's you
know it didn't make up a huge part of my
grade that's a quarter huh but even in
college I made it a point I was like I'm
gonna study all day every day to get an
A in history and I did but I had to work
my ass off for that [ __ ]
because unlike math or science history
doesn't make any [ __ ] sense to
me okay I'm like a logic reason person
you can't reason out like people and
events and dates and names like there's
no reasoning it's just pure memorization
remember Xandra means nothing to me for
the most part you know you learn about
all the basic types of history in high
school and that's our thing okay that's
great I can get that fine sort of except
for that one quarter when I really could
[ __ ] give a [ __ ] less but like once
you get into college you're like none of
this means anything to me I hate all of
this I hate everything you have a hard
time bringing history into some
that would even come close to matter in
your life yeah no I mean it's not like
you're going home and dealing okay I
learn the quadratic formula today I know
how to ride my skateboard it's not good
translates out directly with other
things but I feel like history is so
behind you it's so it's a game of memory
it's not happening it's nothing like
with math you can build on it you can
learn it you can keep going okay it's
done well okay so if you frame it that
way history is a game of memory in my
opinion so as languages well why does
that make language is so much easier
than history maybe it's not for a lot of
people a lot of people are great at
history like they're just nasty at it
yeah but I think it's because they have
an emotional attachment to history you
have to actually feel something when
you're learning about it yeah but
[ __ ] four languages look what do you
do you just say it over and over again
like that's a game of memory that I can
potentially master here I took Spanish
for like eight years
I took Russian for one I crushed it it
was great because it meant something it
meant fun yeah
like what do you learn the colors the
[ __ ] in your room like all right great
this stuff means something to me because
I can see them yeah in maths plural we
don't learn how to sort wages what or
anything to do with the real world
that's very true and I felt like I read
an article recently about how colleges
we're going to start offering sort of
like a real world competency class or
course which seems why does that not
exist purely logical like I don't I
don't currently own a house or anything
like that but i I've been trying I've
been trying to educate myself like basic
fine but nobody's taxes you just wanted
like you're just expected to know it
yeah you are and most people's parents I
feel like I'm I can speak freely about
that and openly most people's parents
aren't helping them do their taxes their
parents are like sucks to be an adult
like oh I don't want to do my taxes I
certainly don't want to help you do your
tan yeah yeah like [ __ ] you yeah no I I
it's incredibly insane you learned sex
ed which isn't even sex that
it's a joke of a class you learn it
makes everything just a little bit
weirder you're [ __ ] at least in my
school district you're forced to do PE
yeah we had to okay but you don't let
opt out we're only allowed to opt out
for one you can only opt out a few a
part of a sports team goes that's what
I'm saying but we were only allowed to
opt out for one quarter yeah you told me
about it see how to be MP for the rest
and you had it yeah you had to be plain
but I just don't get it like you had a
language requirement you had sometimes
physics sometimes you never had a
required class and those doesn't even
exist such a class where you have to
learn basic final right you know easily
you know it you know it existed for us
oh they have personal finance classes
what the [ __ ] no we had Home Economics
which was the closest thing to like a
very old school this is how you cook a
grilled cheese like I got a cook and so
and basically be a housewife but that's
the closest thing to any applicable like
real world knowledge that you're gonna
learn it's not even geared towards all
she's not gear is uncute or anything did
you have home AK did you have to take
that I didn't have a home AK I had AK we
had economics we had micro and macro
okay yeah we had economics - I'm talking
about Hall now we didn't have home AK we
did not have home am I the only one that
had to [ __ ] take that like maybe
that's outdated at this point don't have
sex arrogantly dad um no yeah i-i've
heard of home AK I know people who have
had home AK I just never went to shake
shop or anything
I took woodshop he did a good job in
eighth grade and and the teacher from oh
it's not shopping like you get to do
work across mediums it's just woods I
would shot and the teacher who taught
woodshop he would go to the shack and
have a drink
every Thursday night and Ted would go
and hang out with him - that is
Jillian's yeah that is awesome
who is uh but yeah I took woodshop
that's the closest thing to shop I ever
you know for all those people out there
that are looking for a career in
shopping I built it I don't know what
you're saying I both a badass calendar
there were like long blocks for the
month a wooden block
yeah wooden calendar it was like a
shaped like a like a little dresser and
then there was like long blocks that had
marked in all the spring monk song
sounds very Mayan hey you had to change
it like every like probably three times
a day
sounds like an advent calendar I was so
proud out of her I also made a box Wow
and if you guys ever watch Breaking Bad
you know how important that is
yeah ah you know what I did get to take
in high school this is funny cuz I just
did this video this week that was saying
like I got drunk but for those you
haven't seen it I got drunk and painted
a picture because I was sort of I
struggle with everyday like that I took
a sort of path through college where I'm
like alright I need to like have a job
at the end of this although I would have
taken art school had I thought I was any
good at art and I just haven't had
enough training in art to ever pursue
that as anything so I was like you know
what I'm gonna do I'm just gonna take
myself thar at school but um what I did
get to take in high school that I
thought was really cool was jewelry
making which is well it was so fantastic
because we just like jewelry we cut
metal and then you let you spend I don't
know two-plus weeks like sandpapering it
down so that it doesn't cut the [ __ ] out
of your fingers like you'd make a
pendant but like in some geometric shape
that you really liked that was also easy
to cut with a saw yeah but regardless it
was very cool that you learn how to you
know use your pliers and just make some
[ __ ] jewelry yeah I thought
that was really cool yeah that is cool I
I'm the closest I mean it's a woodshop
my brother took ceramic ceramics was
really popular I didn't get my grandmas
and I also didn't get to take [ __ ]
photography or any sort of film right
here's the deal with that our program um
the ceramics were really popular
yeah everyone would take ceramics I
never said owners would take saran all
the stoners would take scraps I never
take it it's not my first rodeo I tied
you know what's up
I took woodshop in middle school for
Arts in high school what do I can't I
can't even put my finger on what I took
as my art elective in high school oh
okay I took a video see this is why I'm
such a natural on like editing things
and before I even went to college I took
a video editing class and we were using
listen we were stuck in this like bunk
ass stanky dark little room in the back
of campus no one ever [ __ ] cleaned in
high school in high school man I was a
sophomore and we had these we had a
teacher and a TA and I'm pretty sure the
TA and the teacher like slept in a cot
together at the back of the room and
they're both weird dudes sexy such they
were dude which is okay dudes plural
super creepy anyway but they were just
so mean and anal about everything
probably because our classes like
degenerates that made their lives hell
but we like is this an elective yeah
getting yeah the creme de la creme
taking your elephant classes every
semester yeah I guess have you seen Sam
Oh nine-one-one no oh wait it's on it's
on you mean talking to that was in that
class okay so we made weilert we
literally just I mean probably the rest
of the class learned not to interrupt
you but someone just commented on
ustream I had to take tractor shape
safety we legit had to learn how to
drive small track that's dopest dope is
a suckers [ __ ] you and we did all
these video stuff we did we learned on
what you want to do ceramics cuz you're
not a STONER I just didn't want to
probably yeah it's not for those of you
that don't do drugs like Julian and I
feels weird hanging out people that do a
lot of drugs that is right is there
something wrong with me I wish I could
yes don't yeah seriously um anyway I
took this class and like we edited and
honestly I feel like I taught myself
most of what I learned I just got the
opportunity to use the programs which is
what helped yeah but my like my thing
about art in high school is I there was
this ap art program okay it was called
ap art and you could take it as a junior
or senior college got it
your college credits and but basically
it's like the only reason I wanted to
take it is because every other [ __ ]
art class was a piece of [ __ ] and I was
like okay I spent a lot of time drawing
I could probably put together something
that's like half-assed that you know can
be viewed sort of as art so I spent a
[ __ ] long time like probably a month
you know day in and day out try to just
like work on these drawings and
paintings
and I did you had to put put for your
portfolio put like 12 pieces in together
and I was an editing class
no no I'm talking about this is after
that this is my art experience in high
school I already like to experience but
so I bought this thing as pad and I just
[ __ ] went to work I was man when him
and my mom still has pop your mom's his
mom's an artist I'm sorry's um that's
like more than welcomed in your
household especially if you needed help
personally it was probably a big reason
why I did it
yeah but I spent so much time yeah on
these paintings and these drawings yeah
and I submitted it oh yeah and a PR time
was it get into the class into the class
and rejected God you are not good enough
to be in our high school art program and
I was like okay you better give me my
[ __ ] portfolio back cuz that is like
and I was just like [ __ ] that yeah but
like not not that I ever really thought
about going to college for art but after
that I was like what the [ __ ] is my
point I poured everything I know I easy
you if this is your world I don't want
to be a part of this work I have I feel
like I have a similar experience my
first experience with any sort of
entertainment like media I took a class
in college my freshman year called mass
media yeah which is just where you sort
of learn about I don't know [ __ ]
media yeah I feel like I had sort of a
similar experience to that where like
your first experience sort of ruins it
for the rest of the of your life yeah if
that unless you want to revisit it in
college my freshman year I was sort of
undecided you know my Joe's 17 years old
but I decided okay I'm gonna take one
class in like media or like uh whatever
I guess you just called media that's me
yeah what yeah what's that major that
I'm trying to pinpoint uh graphic design
no no no no more way more general than
that media law I don't know no not law
media just like media I don't know
media like sub subgenres of this major
I'm thinking
of our like PR marketing advertising
television film art whatever okay never
mind
irrelevant but I had decided I didn't
know where I wanted to go so took one
psychology class and one media class and
super entry-level I would go to my
psychology class and I would get a
little bit annoyed that everyone thought
that it was story time to talk about
their own personal things but I found
them a little bit more tolerable than
the people in my media class like I
didn't pour my heart and soul into it
and get rejected yeah I just literally
thought it was like Satan's
reincarnation of human beings into this
class and I just couldn't stand it I
could not stand the people and I was
like I'm not cut out communication Thank
You Bridget thank you
dude occations whatever that's the older
teenager got it I just couldn't stand
the idea like if that's the world I
don't want to be in it I don't want to
be a part of it there's no way that I
could ever work or just research do more
than a class I just this because I hate
these people I hate everything about it
and it sort of soured me until after
college I started doing YouTube but I
was like no this is really really cool
and fun I like it
I wish that I'd spent my time getting an
education for it but like I can't I
can't stand it I can't do it
yeah but that that experience of like
pouring your everything and they're just
getting flat-out rejected terrible it's
rough you just realize that you don't
you don't need you tried it and you
you're like no that's so sad Julianne
it's okay you want to hear something
cool oh my brother Marlon he uh given
that he's living at home now for the
summer um what'd she do in college it's
not gonna slam him for that um he moved
back in his old room cuz Sarah left my
cousin and he she did she moved to Santa
Marta
anyways ah I told you that she left a
couple ways to go but he found one of my
paintings
drawings painting no I was painting that
I did for my AP art portfolio
application in my mom's studio and he
put up on his wall he likes it because
it's a picture it's like a three part
picture of a catcher throwing a guy out
yes duh it's pretty sick I was proud
maybe that's why you're our teacher
whoever said yes or no to student
because they suck at sports yeah cuz
they were like uh I don't know this is a
sports picture and I just don't want to
deal with you I spent so much time
getting [ __ ] on for my horrible sports
skills meanwhile someone else drew a
stick figure hanging itself and got
accepted oh it's so deep you need to be
in our class so much symbolism it's so
deep and I like how you left that lying
crook oh no it's just because your
shitty artist
[ __ ] you meas art is so subjective
though you know it's so subjective I
thought like English and writing with
subjective art is the most subjective
because you can call anything art go to
an art museum yeah you'll see it yeah
you'd be like wait what why they would
have a paisa next to it there's like a
picture of a door and instead of windows
they're just like cats and it's like
okay eighty thousand dollars right have
you seen the documentary something about
I think it's Banksy I forget the name of
it but it has to do with Banksy the
artists thanks he's not like Banksy
stuff it's a documentary no I've never
seen it not but he basically there's a
another artist it's sort of [ __ ] you
know fake it till you make it
hmm and he does he makes it he just
sells absolutely crap like ripoff [ __ ] I
forget the name of him in the
documentary but it's that's just a
perfect example of modern art huh you
know you just put like this weird spray
can't just break a painting can't right
there yeah oh my god I can't even speak
spray paint kid that's art by it you
need oh this is like making what your
dough is is is that what that was yes oh
sorry
I'm sorry crevel texted he said to do
that I'm just listening to Greville he
said close down any unneeded programs oh
you like your phone yeah there's too
many things going on no we're having a
conversation sorry I'm trying to fix the
podcast so it works
okay pot can we take a break reliving so
I can set a setting sure all right we'll
be right back all right well where
there's gonna be a lot smoother in the
future we're not how to stop and and
dick like this yeah credible I think
GarageBand might be a little safer
the thing is Pro Tools is probably
better it's just it's very complicated
when you're first learning it yeah we'll
just need to figure out the settings
yeah we'll work on it it'll be a lot
better hello there hi hi we were talking
about stuff and what was that stuff
we're joggin go [ __ ] art what was it
yeah cool Sonia wants to have my pieces
of art what pieces of art from your
portfolio dope dope I told her I'd
Twitpic at her when I next saw them
really mm-hmm
if I even find them if they exist when I
was in high school I got to take one art
class and it was really great and I was
really good at drawing um but because my
dad's really good at art I didn't know
that yeah my dad's like incredible at
art and there's I forget who it is I
think it's my mother's father was
actually a cartoonist for a long time
but so they're sort of like create my
aunt's a painter yeah my aunt won an
Emmy for a news broadcast I know that
like there's art and creativity in my
veins but when I took the class in high
school she was like I want to strongly
encourage you to continue with art but I
couldn't because I had to continue with
clarinet clarinet before everything
we're in it's such a [ __ ] block like God
can't think of a bigger [ __ ] block than
clarinet the recorder that's a bigger
[ __ ] you know in high school that you
had to take an instrument from fourth
grade you can I tell you a sad strange
horn yeah sorry
sad story um so we have to in fourth
grade we had how old are you in fourth
grade your child seven seven so like
they were giving us these demonstrations
of all the instruments the music
teachers were like these are the
woodwinds these are the brass
instruments they're all different
teachers and then so I was so like taken
by the sounds and the
were so good and like oh my god I was so
overwhelmed and so after every teacher
did their little intro of a group of
instruments they would be like if you
want to try out for this intimate
because you would try out for like two
instruments and then at the end of the
day you would decide what you wanted to
play until tenth [ __ ] grade mind you
they don't tell you that then they don't
tell you that you're like investing in
an instrument for a long time how many
years is that eight yeah four five six
seven eight nine ten okay like seven
[ __ ] years so I was sort of just
overwhelmed and I was like oh man I
really like the clarinet I like that Moe
[ __ ] clarinet but I could get down
with that flute but what I really want
to do is play those drums so the drum
guy did his intro and then he was like
and I was so like overwhelmed with the
drums like I loved them and he they tell
you what room to go to in the music room
to try out for them and then they tell
you based on your natural ability where
chances are good good but you can pick
whatever injury you want strings [ __ ]
whatever so when the guy did the drums I
was like that's my calling that's my
life and mind you I was an incredibly
shy terrified of authority child yeah so
I was like all right I like that
clarinet I like that flute so I went to
the woodwind room I remembered where
that was I remembered the lady with her
bangs and whatever and I try to open the
clarinet she was like you're amazing at
flute clarinet and I was like I want to
play the flute that's weird they carry
that with little case to school I don't
like that I want to play the clarinet
that's a little better but can you
please point me to where the drums are
no I get finished playing the clarinet
it goes BB BB beep times up gotta [ __ ]
go to your next class and then the next
day we decided which instruments we play
and there was already a drama and I
never tried out for the drums I never
even got to it was honestly this is my
school no Minos I was SEVIS Oh cassis oh
my G school you could have been the best
percussionist ever I better than Sheila
E I never got to try out for the drums
and I I still
to this day I'm so torn up about it
because little seven-year-old Jenna just
that's heartbreaking
I was released you needed to fulfill you
need to get on those Durant's and I you
know quietly and diligently and
obediently played clarinet until 10th
grade that's [ __ ] they kept you in a
box you need to be on those drums can't
hold Jenna down
why are you crying hold Jenna down like
that just won't play drums like think
about like I have a lot of energy a lot
of like I want to just bang on [ __ ] you
know
I dunno no I just sit there like this do
you have a way to get any sort of
percussion set here no I played uh when
I went to like a girl all-girls camp I
played a bongos for a hot minute I was
really good at that I crushed it with
your hand right yeah eyelash does get
legs get hands get hands let's go
but if ever if I'm given a second
opportunity in life to learn some drums
yeah I will not simply piano for a long
time you played Crenshaw played the
could the court recorder cuz I did it i
whatever ass dude I play the French horn
for a year girl I [ __ ] you want to
hear a funny story about [ __ ] French
horn I told us the other night tell it
all the time here and I like your story
but um yes I play the drums on rock band
yes I do I never had rock and only had
Guitar Hero um you should do a video
playing the clarinet I would if my mom
would [ __ ] send my clarinet to me
every year my mom's like I'm gonna send
you your clarinet Debbie get off Twitter
and send us a Clarence Debbie Debbie
Debbie put the Twitter machine down said
me make clear what's your swag down and
send a clarinet but the the French horn
um it's fine it's whatever but I was
renting a room in my apartment in Boston
and my do this is like I don't I don't
know one square feet how to describe
this like slightly larger than a closet
this is a four-bedroom apartment and the
teeniest tiniest little [ __ ] the
whole apartment is a closet and this is
the closet with in a closet closet
section
and that everything's shitty the floors
are [ __ ] gross like discussing a
hellhole and so I was renting this
little closet room so you just need
someone to live there the rent was
cheaper than the rest of the house
fair leave it's you know half the size
of a regular room yeah in the regular
rooms tiny my room was tiny so this
[ __ ] girl comes over she's got a
notepad right like she's taking notes
she's taking this very seriously like I
don't know like I'm just you know she's
asked me all these questions and I'm
like look [ __ ] this is a shitty dump of
an apartment like what are you looking
for who do you what is your budget three
hundred to four hundred dollars a month
like are you looking for some [ __ ]
luxury no like you get what you get this
is what we're offering you and so then
after I take her around the whole
[ __ ] dump of a place she looks at me
and goes you know after she asked ten
thousand questions she goes um so I play
the French horn which is one of the
louder brass instruments and I need to
practice approximately three to six
hours a day is that going to be a
problem and I was like get out there's
the door
get the [ __ ] out like I'm not even gonna
entertain the idea of filling my room
right now if you are my option get out
I'm not gonna listen to your
[ __ ] French horn and
afterthought is that gonna be a problem
is that gonna be a problem yeah [ __ ] you
like I think we need to disclose up
front if you play loud musical
instruments for six hours a day is a
long time do you mean yeah it's like a
fourth of the day imagine okay all day
Saturday all day Sunday look I'm
assuming three to six means weekdays she
practices three hours weekends she
practices six hours imagine all day like
you wake up this [ __ ] [ __ ] wakes up
at 9:30 in the morning on a Saturday cuz
you know she's not going now know this
girl was like hi V she's not going
anywhere
she's high vis she's like she's gonna
wake up early is [ __ ] on Saturday
morning you're gonna woke it broken up
every weekend for a year to do
that's grounds for murder
yeah I could understand murder yeah
that's a martyr's understand murder
relateable de 296 of that no it's past
just no you're done get out yeah get out
so that was my my sort of inside joke to
myself every time I wrote a [ __ ]
Craigslist post thereafter I was like
you know right the my piece about the
apartment in a nice comical way like we
live in a [ __ ] come live in a
[ __ ] like whatever and then at the
bottom in all caps would be like no
French horn players which most people
interpreted to be very funny which I
appreciate it that's that is funny
that's like you got to write your
craigslist post yeah with intention so
mine was only always humorous and then
you draw the right people do you mean
yeah the best roommates ever had if I'm
in Craigslist it's like it's
automatically attracting people with
your sense of humor
yeah people they don't get it don't
apply yep
don't apply you only have to deal with
them no like what is this is this
anglish I thought I knew English but
that's not it well that girl looked at
that post maybe in the future when she
got kicked out of her next apartment and
was like well I guess I play French horn
and it explicitly says no French horn
play that is the best idea I've seen
kill her with no furniture with the
French horn oh my god yes yep you played
the French wine I play the French horn
for a year and I have a story yeah I
sucked I basically kept quiet in all of
our concerts because I was so did you
hear play like air blowing oh I was the
[ __ ] airplane king well that
helicopter I don't know I don't they
call it julienning because I did it all
the time I had like three concerts my
whole year what I think is like seven
and I would not have white balls oh yeah
that's the band concert attire yeah the
white shirt the white t-shirt boy and
you sit down I had this store okay my
friend uh who I play the French hard
with I had two friends who I knew had a
friend that you played the friend Y for
they were friends before the French horn
ever my friends after their French eh
but yeah his name is Dax I also knew a
guy named Joe we both we all three kind
of knew each other yeah
so we play we were the French forum you
know friends ever ever your dogs crying
ja Dax he you know one time I need to
borrow his French horn cuz I didn't I
didn't have mine why didn't you to
borrow well I went back and forth to my
mom and dad's house and it was hard to
[ __ ] remember I just bustard wonder I
shouldn't have assumed it was that easy
I was flustered one day okay
alright um so I didn't have my French
horn and I need it I need it so I just
remember taking his French horn thinking
okay this is his it's not like it's the
schools and I can just hide it when I
return it it's his and he cared enough
to get his own and I [ __ ] it into it
well maybe his parents were rich and
they can just buy French horns like
there's no tomorrow
did I has a rent mine my clarinet yeah
no no I rented mine yeah I'm I'm a
renter instrument I don't want to find
things like a couple hundred bucks man
um no Dax is a good guy I play baseball
with him all through high school we knew
each other forever um but does he still
play French horn
no so it's not that is it is everything
ended up for the best
yeah it ended up great but it's like one
of those things here let's go back to
this before we get to the book thing can
we stop on embarrassing stories as a kid
yes because this is this leads right
into that well this is the type of thing
that you talk about yeah
sorry okay Julian needs to tell you his
embarrassing you guys have seen I've
done videos in the past about my
embarrassing stories and there's just
this one story that Julian tells from
high school is it the Locker one it hits
me right in the fields no it's not the
locker one you know the one that I'm
talking about yes that one please tell
it I'm [ __ ] what which one is it the
dance the dance yeah the girl that oh
yeah okay come on okay sorry alright
okay this this story just hits me right
in the fields tell it alright this is
girl um her name is Haley and uh I was
young well I I don't think I was it was
middle school cuz that was the three
most Awkward years of my entire life
what's in minutes it was middle who's in
high school I blame him um I'm pretty
sure there were outside parties telling
me to ask her to the dance I didn't
really do it on my own I had people
telling me to so I was like okay that's
how middle school works oh hey come to
James May she was like okay yeah and she
loved she was like happy [ __ ] and she
like went to her friends and was like
talking about it and so here's how it
went for me I had PE six period so I
would go home after PE which would mean
I would go home in my PE clothes but the
way the dance works because we were all
so young and responsible was the dancers
like maybe an hour and a half after the
last bell of school so you could
feasibly stay at school and just go
straight to the dance which I did but
what I would do is our play PE I would
play basketball like PE and then the
bell rang and I would play a little more
basketball yeah after the Bellas I'm
school and I would have my mom come a
little later because I wanted to play
basketball with my friends
um and the dance day came it was like a
Friday and it was no different I was
just like okay yeah I know that there's
something I have to be at in the gym or
whatever I'll do that later so I play
basketball two hours passes I come over
to the gym like with my friends I meet
up with some friends and I'm wearing my
PE clothes which are like probably like
four or five sizes too big on me because
I'm
kid and I meet up with my date and she
walks in the door did up to the nines
like she's wearing a prom dress yells
makeup hair she's all the way she's all
the way gonna [ __ ] up like and Jillian
justin is gym club and is my man my gym
clothes I'm wearing my shitty shitty
sneakers my unwashed like shorts and
t-shirt cuz you don't wash them you
leave in your locker you like it um I'm
like hey she's like hey and I could see
like the excitement sink in her look
yeah I just complete his appointment and
but I don't know if I told you even this
part her mom's a photographer so she
would take a camera everywhere to take
pictures oh yeah oh yeah
huge photographer you shouldn't find
those pictures there I could I probably
could fan and I know how to I need yeah
um so yeah that's that's how I
disappointed the first girl I ever truly
disappointed I showed up so sad cuz you
can't like there's so many times in your
life where you know you should feel bad
I want and like I don't want to say like
you should feel bad I'm saying like in
theory you know you feel bad but like
when you tell it again or when you think
about that moment you just feel so bad
and went the first time the Julian told
me that story about you know meeting up
with this girl that's of course just
thinking that this is a dance and we're
like oh my god I got asked to the dance
and I'm gonna dress up in a dress and
for those of you girls out there you
know how long this [ __ ] [ __ ] takes
doing you nails in your hair and your
makeup and finding a dress finding a
dress alone could be a weekend long
process so she just was so all [ __ ]
ready and then you're just like of
course you're acting like it an eighth
grade or seventh grade boy you just show
up in gym clothes because you're just
like why would I do it I'm such an
[ __ ] you're not though because that's
how [ __ ] boys are just means yeah
because to you that makes total perfect
sense I didn't think Theresa as to her
it makes total perfect sense that going
to a dance means
need to look like Cinderella it was just
such the icing on the cake though that
her mom was like a professional
photographer at the camera add insult
injury like now you gotta take fifty
million pictures of us like this yep it
hits me in the field is it I told you to
start we gotta talk about books okay
whatever but I just quickly yeah to tell
your story the one story from me that
reminds me of that sinking horrible
feeling it's nothing it means nothing
me and my brother like we used to love
to eat toaster strudels they're so good
they're [ __ ] amazing we did like
pop-tarts - but toaster strudels were
like gourmet pop-tart yeah and uh so
every time the weekend would roll around
where we were just like [ __ ] oh man
time to eat some [ __ ] toaster
strudels like some eggs bacon whatever
my brother's giant kid he's huge he's
[ __ ] I think he was like six three by
the time he was in seventh or eighth
grade huh he's a big boy he needs a lot
of food and so I think I was you know in
middle school old enough to be like not
a child and uh so I go downstairs my
brother usually usually slept into like
1 p.m. on the weekends which to me was
like what do you do but now it leaves no
no you were right you were right Devin
so I go downstairs like 10:30 or
whatever when I wake up I go and I open
the toaster strudels there's one left
thinking that there's like another box
in there whatever make it like great my
brother comes downstairs like 1 o'clock
weekends are like magical things when
you're in middle school Oh in high
school and he opens the freezer and
there's like nothing in it and he just
looks at me and he goes into my mom
she's in the kitchen - and he goes now
there's nothing special for me to eat as
I put like a bite of toaster strudel in
my mouth and I just sat there and I went
where you cried I like started sobbing
and my mom hysterically starts crying
and my brother starts laughing and like
she's like no it's okay and there's just
no consoling me like I just felt so
horrible that I had eaten the last
toaster strudel and the look of pure
sadness and disappointment of her
frolics face I couldn't get over it I
couldn't get over it that's funny they
crying he's nice sobbed I stopped and my
mom was I think my mom you know like
made him some [ __ ] bacon and pancakes
or something yeah like everything was
fine but I just it like it's one of
those times where it's it shouldn't like
I guess sure I should be you sure you
should be upset but like you shouldn't
be as upset as you are and I my heart
[ __ ] just dropped just like it just
hit me all in the fields yeah yeah the
way that that girl dressing up and you
being like oh no just hits everybody in
the fields you know it's really funny
cause it's like indicative of your
mindset at that age yeah those stories
it like takes you through every way your
mind so incredibly like sad or
embarrassing like everything is just
emotions on steroids yeah just your
hormones a little I body I'm hormone
feels so many field high body em
hormones in Hawaii I'm actually hormones
him actually hormones oh you got to talk
about [ __ ] a book that everyone
should read look that everyone should
read uh I like the book called The
Alchemist by Paulo Coelho I've never
read that it's a really good book
um I remember reading it when I was
going into eighth grade I was going into
eighth grade and it was the summer
before eighth grade and I went to like a
vacation with my buddies we went to like
New Yorker it was like one of the
Thousand Islands or something and on the
airport ride back this is how
procrastination was I bought it on
before we got an airplane I read on the
plane most of it at least but it was
like a really kind of heartwarming like
go get him story it's you can't really
you know you got to read it's a good
book it's about this kid who you know he
just kind of encounters all sorts of
different people and in his quest to
become whatever he's trying to become
which he doesn't even realize what it is
but it's a good book I you know every
time I think of what book I really loved
that book just comes to mind I just
enjoy the story the the journey that he
goes on it's kind of cheesy but it's a
very simple story but I think it's
important that type of story so you
can't be distracted but but no you can't
hey that's just popped up I don't run
Julianne [ __ ] oh okay this is why you
can't have Twitter and podcasts and
Ustream I didn't know it was anyway I
just popped up anyway that's my that's
my book what is your book my book is
this is stupid cuz I also read it like
in middle school but I read plenty of
[ __ ] things in college and all that
that you know are meaningful or whatever
and I guess it matters like what kind of
person you are what sort of experiences
or life things you've been through for
certain things speak to people more than
other things but for me something that
like hit me in the the brain was [ __ ]
All Quiet on the Western Front you read
that book oh I've never read that book
I've heard that a bunch though it's just
you know about the [ __ ] war about
[ __ ] world
I don't even [ __ ] know one yeah well
I won and uh it it just [ __ ] hits you
in the fields you know how are you like
thirteen thirteen twelve or thirteen and
out like I just remember I hated I'm
sorry to anyone that likes these [ __ ]
books but I hated [ __ ] Tom Sawyer To
Kill a Mockingbird I hated like
everything that you had to read hated it
like I literally I know it's bad to say
but I in so many ways
destroyed my school's copy of To Kill a
Mockingbird
because I hated it so much yeah I
[ __ ] I fully shove it down your
throat yeah they tell you what you have
to read and how you should feel about it
but I feel like all Quiet on the Western
Front since it was about a war and it's
like a first-person perspective of the
war they like there's no teacher that's
gonna sit there and tell you how to feel
you feel how you feel joining me yeah
and I I just I felt a lot of things in
that book and I think it's really
important especially for a young person
to always put yourself in the shoes of
what your life could be like if there
were a draft if people have to go to war
that's very realistic and there's people
that are currently at war and have been
their entire lives and that's all that
they know training yeah like there's not
a day that goes by where I'm not like
hey you know what's great there we're
not we're not in a war-torn country full
of terrorists and things like that
that's spectacular and it just it's a
the way that it's written is very ya
know I asked I I think things good point
no they said men I think I think a
problem I had with a lot of the English
classes I took in high school was
basically like what you just said that
they tell you what to feel and I felt
like uh I don't know you read Kafka you
read like the metamorphosis and you read
these sort of things where there is
literally so much that you can
extrapolate off of based on your own
mind like this is all you're reading it
one who reads it is gonna think about it
differently but for you to sit in a
class with one person up front writing
on a board telling you what led what a
[ __ ] thing I just I feel like that's
that's probably a big reason why I never
got huge into reading because I always
felt like I had to be in a box I never
read a book like this means if you ever
write a paper that's not what the
teacher is telling you that you don't
get a good grade yeah it's just love The
Velveteen Rabbit Oh
all right let's [ __ ] let's
extrapolate on that like what's your
favorite like story story or did you
read a book like when you were a little
kid like I always used to speaking of
The Velveteen Rabbit I did read that but
I always were used to reading this book
called pat the bunny it's literally like
a furry insert into a children's book
and you turn the page and you pat the
bunny hmm I love that [ __ ] that's cute
coming from someone that did not become
overly stimulated visually seriously I
wanted a path that mother [ __ ] bunny
that was entertainment I'll pat the
bunny every single [ __ ] night can
weary pat the bunny again yeah for me uh
I don't even know the [ __ ] name of it
hopefully you guys can help me it was
about this dog with with her black spots
Dirty Harry no no maybe I don't know no
he had black spots use a white dog with
black spots but you go out into the
world and get so dirty
yeah Dirty Harry right and you come back
as a black dog with white spots
something dirty dirty something yeah
that was mine Hoppus that was mine I
know exactly what you're talking about
that book is [ __ ] adorable amazing a
netbook made me so happy enjoy I love
that book you know a book I really liked
when I was younger but then I grew up to
have that sat like same sad sinking
feeling we were talking about the book
are you my mother
oh my god yeah through I forget what
kind of animal it is and the same way
with gonzo in the Muppets it was sort of
like are you my mother and yeah this
this if you give a mouse a cookie um it
was this affricate what kind of animal
was but it go around just asking like a
tractor like a light like a lamppost
a dog a cat oh are you my mother
are you my mother and I'm like this is a
[ __ ] sad
that's the saddest book ever like you
just don't know where you fit into the
world are you my mother and where the
[ __ ] is my mother where the [ __ ] is my
mom ya Joe was so sad it's that's like a
really kind of cryptic message for you
to be reading as a kid it's like so yeah
it's serious it's like dark and leave
your adopted you'll never find Thank You
my mail people what is their time I
think the reason I like that dog book is
because he was so like expected to be
this clean healthy like normal dog dirty
dog see I told you I said to hell with
her I think I think a big like Thank You
Sonia he was expected to be this like
average dog who stayed clean but you
know what that's not him he won her is
gonna [ __ ] go Harry Harry I'll be
here Harry go Harry
hey good ol hair like he comes back and
he's all black and dirty he's got little
whites I just I don't I love that and
also Miss Morgan's lon I don't know that
was Miss Morgan's lon
it was about these kids who played ball
in their backyards and every time they
hit a ball over their fence they would
go next door to Miss Morgan's lon and
they'd never get a ball back once it was
in Miss Morgan's lon it was you could
kiss exact it sounds like a [ __ ] she's
a grade-a [ __ ] she's mean and she she
would never give a ball back so finally
one time they went over there and
they're like oh what the [ __ ] where's
all our balls and there's just [ __ ]
balls everywhere and they're like Miss
Morgan why don't you give us our balls
back like all we want to do is play I'm
sorry sensitive and it gets down to the
bottom of like the end of the story is
like Miss Morgan is just crotchety
because she's crotchety and they call
her ass out and then they get the balls
back but that's the moral of the story
well I haven't read I feel like I
haven't rolled on I haven't read it in a
long time but I could relate at the time
because I was a kid kicking balls over
the fence everything all day yeah I feel
like the moral of the story should have
been the person who keeps throwing the
balls over the wall that person's parent
is like I'm not buying more balls tell
me
they're [ __ ] going this shit's
expensive and then the kids parent goes
over there and says excuse me miss
Morgan you have about [ __ ] $3,000
with the [ __ ] balls in your yard can
I get them back for my kid
Thanks [ __ ] you and then you just throw
a ball through her window that is a
Molotov cocktail on it yeah I'll talk
ball yeah I feel stupid for bringing
that book up and not remembering exactly
how it comes to a conclusion but I just
remember like just Miss Morgan's lon but
she you go back there and there's the
balls everywhere balls and balls and
balls we had but we we had a ball
everywhere in our backyard yeah I know
me too
yes have you seen the book about the
traveling dick that's what her de lijn
asks no I haven't I don't know what that
is but the happy argue my mother was a
little baby bird that fell out of the
nest that makes sense are you my mother
make sense that's so sad really sad what
else Julian have you I read the book
good night moon yeah course love that
book they read it last year cuz I took
an education class and uh that's
adorable I read the whole thing you took
an education class is that that learning
value in difference in whatever that was
technically in education class ah that's
kid I have a message between counseling
and education I know it counts for lots
of things it's like three [ __ ] things
that degree sports psychology counseling
through the School of Education yeah you
can do a lot of things you would ever
the dick I want like this kitten legs
miss podcasts if I want to miss miss
miss get eggs me did you [ __ ] masters
miss I said masters with a P um well I'm
happy we did this
yeah me too I'm happy we tried it out
and I love the idea of keeping our core
[ __ ] homies on Ustream while we do
this because it helps it helps us move
things along it helps us give a little
bit interaction
while we tried it because honestly
sitting here and trying to do a whole
podcast it's not going to be easy you
know by any means but having you guys
here is is definitely awesome so we're I
feel like next time we want you know
once we recorded another episode of this
we will have our [ __ ] figured out
technical wise we won't have to stop but
we if you are on board I think we should
do the Ustream taya Graham yeah I think
it's great it's really fun having
Ustream and for those of you that are
watching or listening if you want to be
a part of the Ustream because we're
gonna like I'm not gonna [ __ ] shout
the podcast on the mountaintops I like
it being sort of like good to me to
whoever wants to find it in watch or
listen finds it yeah but if you're
listening currently if you want to be on
the Ustream I don't when are we gonna do
this probably Friday nights I think
Friday I think Friday nights is when
we're gonna report late popularly or
Thursday nights
those are pregnancy I think both of
those uh options but follow Julian on
Twitter at Julian sulamita right yeah at
Julian's for me yo ello mi mi take to
you the only honestly there's 16 million
it there's 16 people watching this it's
pretty sure you all know my Twitter cuz
otherwise I don't know how the [ __ ] you
found the substrate for the video in the
podcast got it very well good telling
you stream I already know that's why
they're here yes Julian sold me on
Twitter I'll tweet out the link if you
want to be part of the Ustream
absolutely um but yeah this was awesome
um like I said every week we're gonna
get better yeah
some weeks we're gonna be short some
works for me long sometimes we might
even have someone here no rules yes no
we gotta get our [ __ ] friends in here
I want you guys to meet my friends and
Julian's yeah we got some funny funny
you have some really funny friends that
are not youtubers they're not [ __ ]
what they're just right just human
beings in their epic but they're just
yeah Rachel on this podcast with a drink
in her hand that be yes yes uh be mark
mark you guys need to see mark okay
Michael these names mean nothing thank
you so much for tuning in to our yeah
podcast thanks to our sponsors which is
that doesn't really work right yeah
thanks for thanks for your support
[ __ ] that doesn't really work rightfully
but hopefully there will be more of
these and this has been fun and this is
usually what we do over the weekend
right happy we're recording this for the
internet system this is what we we are
[ __ ] do we get a drink and we just
say here and talk yeah so I want to talk
about glad that we did this I'm excited
to be back spectacular we did it J&J
podcast but it's not J&J it's Julianne
Jetta
no it's Jenna and Julian your friend
Jenna and Julian your first well
alphabetically speaking I'm first you're
first in the podcast all right we
actually have Twitter Instagram YouTube
all set up we just haven't released it
so alright alright sounds good we are
hoping to do this every week but who the
[ __ ] knows who knows we will no
expectations no rules no expectations
those rules we're gonna try to be as
consistent as possible but at the same
time living by our anti rule rule cool
we love you guys alright love you see
you guys next time see you next week bye
bye
you